what do you think of the um
interviews with michael saylor where
where he basically describes bitcoin and
like digital real estate do you think
that that bitcoin is digital real estate
is it the equivalent of
like a building with rental income
i mean because you can stake bitcoin it
can earn you interest and it and it is
generally going to appreciate in value
the way that it's been designed
yeah let's just explain something you
know this here
the zen dollar the u.s dollar doesn't
make any difference
counterparty risk is the government of
zimbabwe
and the reason i recommend gold server
bitcoin big is because the u.s dollar if
this was a u.s dollar the counterparty
risk is the fed the treasury and wall
street
it's i trust bitcoin
more than i trust biden
you can get to that level of
intelligence you got it i'm a marine
yeah i trust this pad more than i trust
government
that's what i'm saying
it's it's that simple keep it simple you
know what i mean yeah
um do i like bitcoin
yeah because i bought it at 6 000
would i buy it today maybe not
you know what i mean and all these guys
i've you know i've been i've been around
long enough
when somebody is telling me it's going
to 1.5 million
you know bitcoin is
i got to be careful
that's like when a stock comes up oh
yeah yeah yeah you know like tesla
is now what
a thousand dollars a share or something
well well do you think bitcoin will
displace gold as a store of value
because i mean do you think bitcoin will
because gold's worth about 10 trillion
on the market i think as a market cap
and bitcoin if i'm not mistaken it's
just over a trillion so basically 10xing
bitcoin brings it up to 600 000.
my concern is written this i'll be
upfront because the bitcoin guys will
trash me for this one but yeah there's
all this new technology coming out
and bitcoin might be old technology
i'm not saying it is or not i'm just
saying as a skeptic
as a professional investor i've got to
watch all sides of it
got it and where gold and silver gold is
i call gold and silver god's money
because they're part of the element with
the periodic table
you know they're part of god
i'm not religious but i'm saying and
i've been i've i've started gold mines
and silver mines took them public on
tour in toronto i hang out in you know
vancouver
where all the crooks of the world hang
out in resource industry
so i love i love canada you know because
every frito bandito hangs out in
vancouver i've heard every
story possible
but that's why i like the game you know
i love it
but if you're gonna be so stupid to take
my word for it then that's your problem
you know if i
i if i told you right now bitcoin is six
thousand dollars how many people would
buy it well everybody would
right but at the time it was frightening
because it went from 20
dropped almost went off the chart to
zero
it stabilized at three i watched it
there it hit six and i bought 65 bitcoin
because i don't trust the dollar
if you can understand that that was a
good move
i don't trust the treasury and i don't
trust biden
um
another super chats roberts uh thank you
you were the first video 60 minutes to
getting rich i saw about the rat race
and finance it changed my life big time
could you talk about the rat race
because i uh because i had a note over
here
according to rich dad the poor and
middle class revolves around a pattern
the pattern of getting up going to work
paying bills the cycle repeats over and
over again
this is what robert kiyosaki refers to
as a rat race can you talk about the rat
race a little bit yeah the rat race is
on my game board you know what what i do
is i take what you know vernacular we
all use one in the rat race
but also there's the fast track
and the fast track is the capitalist
track and to get on to the fast track
you gotta have one of these but they
don't teach you at school
they teach you get good grades but my
bankers never asked me what my grade
point average was
my banker just wants to know is my money
coming from here
how many assets do i have
and like i said i have about 8 000
rental units plus commercial plus this
plus businesses plus
you know i just focus here
where school teaches you to focus here
how much income can you make and the
trouble with income
is your first lions tax
and marx and lenin says you want to kill
the you want to kill capitalism you
grind them through inflation and
taxation
is that going on today yes we just
printed 10 trillion dollars in the us
canada your scores according to the bis
the bank of international settlements
you guys are the worst in the world
you know it's and i know house i love
canada
you know i'm there all the time my
companies i took my company's public in
toronto
not nasdaq
do what i mean so i love canada but
still you know how socialistic you guys
are and especially that happened in
montreal
when they wanted to what's it called yes
what did the french wanted to do they
wanted to oh they wanted to separate
from canada
yeah yeah the separatist separatist so
that's going outside this is what i'm
saying it's all going on outside
the question is what's going on inside
and that's why you guys have helped me
i've helped with other with money
problems but that's that's why
it's education but you got to take care
of yourself inside
yeah
um
cal just with a 69 super chat uh thanks
prices thank you robin rich for doing
this hashtag chase excellence
the competent man has another one here
you